Public Sénat et écho DDS vous présente
pourvu que ça dure
[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure l'émission qui rend les cours
responsable sur Public Sénat elle est
petite question connaissez-vous les
métaux stratégiques lithium nickel
cobalt Terra tous sont indispensables à
l'expansion de nos énergies
renouvelables des métaux souvent
extraits de manière polluante c'est pas
très éthique à l'autre bout du monde et
bien avec les crises géopolitiques et
notre demande qui explose comment
sécuriser nos approvisionnements pour
réussir notre transition énergétique
réponse avec le journaliste Guillaume
Pitron le lithium justement qui occupe
une place centrale dans la transition
écologique et s'il était possible
aujourd'hui de le produire chez nous en
France reportage chez Ramette qui a pris
une extrait prochainement dans
l'Hexagone et puis le recyclage des
batteries des voitures électriques est
peut-être une solution pour retrouver
notre souveraineté le patron de Vercors
qui se lance avec Renault dans
l'aventure les gigas Factory nous dira
pourquoi mais d'abord tout ce qu'il faut
savoir sur les métaux stratégiques en
moins d'une minute c'est parti les
métaux stratégiques c'est quoi ce sont
les métaux dont notre économie a besoin
notamment pour réussir notre une
transition énergétique c'est le cas du
lithium du cobalt du nickel du cuivre ou
encore des terres rares mais on les
trouve où exactement dans les batteries
des voitures électriques qui ont besoin
de beaucoup de cuivre de nickel de
lithium et de cobalt mais également dans
les éoliennes constituées de cuivre de
zinc de nickel de cobalt et aussi d'un
peu de terre rare ou encore dans les
panneaux solaires qui sont composés de
cuivre de silicium et d'un peu de terre
rare et on risque d'en manquer et oui
tous ces métaux nous les importons de
Chine de Russie de la République
démocratique du Congo ou encore
d'Amérique du Sud or pour nous
décarboner nous allons avoir besoin de
beaucoup beaucoup de métaux plus 3500%
pour le lithium plus 2600% pour les
terres rares ou encore plus 330% pour le
cobalt en Europe la demande va exploser
d'ici 2050 il n'y en aura pas pour tout
le monde ce qui risque de mettre en
péril notre transition énergétique
[Musique]
comment réussir notre transition
énergétique alors que les métaux
stratégiques vont être amenées à manquer
bonjour Guillaume Pitron bonjour David
Jacquot cet auteur de la guerre des
métaux rares aux éditions les liens qui
libèrent d'abord de quoi parle-t-on
pardon déjà de poser un peu le décor les
métaux stratégiques c'est vrai qu'ils
sont partout et pourtant on les connaît
pas bien il y a pas de voiture
électrique il y a pas de d'éolienne il
n'y a pas de panneaux solaires sans eux
c'est clair ça en fait des métaux
stratégiques ce sont des métaux qui sont
indispensables pour une industrie
considérée comme stratégique par un État
en France nos industries stratégiques
c'est notamment la l'industrie
automobile et donc les métaux qui certes
à fabriquer les voitures électriques
sont des métaux qui sont éminemment
stratégiques on parle du lithium on
parle également du cuivre on parle du
cobalt du nickel d'un minerai qui
s'appelle le graphite tous ces métaux
sont avant de venir de plus en plus
important on ne pourra pas on ne peut
pas d'ores et déjà on ne pourra pas
faire de transition énergétique que sans
eux juste un chiffre pour bien
imprimer cette idée
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
nous dit que dans les 20 ans qui
viennent dans 20 ans notre consommation
de lithium dans le monde sera 42 fois
supérieure à ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
lithium qui sert qui va servir
majoritairement pour les batteries des
véhicules électriques voilà et donc
c'est métaux sont rares certains sont
rares d'autres sont abondants il faut
s'y retrouver un petit peu aussi les
métaux abondants cuivre fer aluminium
zinc et puis des métaux stratégiques
mais ils sont pas rares tout à fait ils
sont stratégiques mes parents en tout
cas le cuivre peut être considéré comme
un métal éminemment stratégique parce
qu'il en faut pour les voitures
électriques et puis après vous avez des
métaux plus rares que les métaux
abondants parce que 1000 fois plus rare
2000 fois plus rares dans les corps
terrestres que les grands métaux donc ça
veut dire qu'ils sont très dilués et
donc on peut les considérer comme rares
alors naturellement on en trouve
jusqu'au fond des océans de ces métaux
comme les terres rares ou le cobalt donc
ils sont rares et pas rares à la fois
mais l'industrie aime bien les qualifier
de rares parce que plus dilué et donc il
faut bien les chercher à un coût
écologique très élevé pardon c'est quoi
les terres rares alors les terres rares
c'est une classe de rares qui se
subdivise en 15 métaux dont le néodyme
qui est important pour les aimants qui
font fonctionner les moteurs de la
plupart d'une voiture électrique mais
vous avez également du néodyme dans
votre téléphone portable il fait vibrer
votre téléphone portable donc les terres
c'est une sous-catégorie encore les
demandes justement pour ces métaux
stratégiques bon exploser ça on a bien
compris dans les prochaines années
décennies et ce qu'on va en manquer
c'est ça le sujet et le risque il est là
et lesquels métaux stratégie rares
critiques sont les plus concernés alors
d'abord il faut savoir qu'il y a pas de
limite géologique il y a des limites
géologiques mais il y a pas de rareté
géologique comme je vous l'ai dit de ces
métaux on peut en trouver jusqu'au fond
des océans et pourquoi pas sur la crête
des astéroïdes donc sur le papier il y a
tout ce qu'on veut le problème c'est à
quel coup est-ce qu'on va aller les
extraire la teneur des gisements baisse
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut creuser
toujours plus profondément générer
toujours plus de rebut il faut consommer
davantage d'électricité pour extraire la
même quantité de matière il faut plus
d'eau pour aller raffiner la même
quantité de matière avec un coût
écologique plus élevé or les populations
sont pas forcément d'accord et ça c'est
un goût étranglement extrêmement
important le politique finit par hésiter
et voir si oppose et donc en fait vous
avez un ensemble de critères qui en fait
font que le métal pourrait ne pas être
extrait suffisamment par rapport à la
demande donc générer des situations de
pénurie non pas parce qu'il est encore
une fois rare dans les corps terrestres
mais parce que les coûts d'extraction
sont-elles et les enjeux que finalement
on se dit on préfère s'en passer et
c'est là le risque est-ce que ce sont
toujours des pays fréquentables ou pas
qui produit ces métaux stratégiques
alors l'Australie est un pays tout à
fait fréquentable le Chili est un pays
fréquentable le problème c'est qu'une
partie de la production de ces pays
rachetée par des entreprises chinoises
et ces entreprises chinoises exportent
importent le minerai jusque sur le
territoire chinois et c'est en Chine qui
va être affiné donc c'est à dire qu'il
va être affiné en utilisant une
électricité raffinée ça veut dire
raffiné c'est à dire qu'il va être
transformé en produits finis prêt à être
utilisés dans les cellules des batteries
or l'électricité qui permet sera finage
c'est une électricité qui du charbon
majoritairement Chine donc vous avez
paradoxe des énergies bas carbone et
demain des voitures bas carbone qui en
fait qui en fait pour pour la
fabrication desquelles il a fallu
émettre du CO2 donc est-ce que c'est
fréquentable d'aller acheter du minerai
en Chine non pas vraiment est-ce que
c'est fréquentable d'aller acheter du
métal en Chine non donc l'enjeu demain
ça va être mais comment est-ce qu'on se
passe de la Chine y compris des
batteries chinoises parce qu'on achète
carrément les batteries au chinois et
comment on extrait tout ça de manière
propre responsable et responsable alors
chez nous voilà donc propre on met ce
matin de côté ça n'arrivera jamais
interdit notre vocabulaire jusqu'à la
fin des temps d'accord sur la méthode
stratégie ne fera jamais de mine propre
c'est un mythe mais on fera pas non plus
germinal et la psyché française autour
des moments de côté l'ami du futur sera
entre les deux et ce sera une mine que
l'on peut qualifier de responsable
c'est-à-dire que nous allons extraire le
minerai selon des critères et des normes
sociales environnementales qui seront
plus respectueuses que ce qu'on a pu
faire par le passé et puis respectueuse
que ce que font les moi et donc c'est là
cette sur cette fine ligne de crête que
on doit pouvoir relancer une industrie
minière notamment en Europe pour pouvoir
avoir nos propres approvisionnements à
un coût écologique moindre ça se joue
donc à l'échelle nationale et surtout
européenne on sait que la Commission
européenne l'Europe est en train de
bouger pour retrouver un peu de
souveraineté en la matière ça passe déjà
peut-être par changer nos fournisseurs
tout à fait changer un petit peu la
cartographie je sais pas quels sont les
pays qui pourraient être visés le Canada
notamment oui
le chancelier allemand à rendu visite à
son homologue Justine Trudeau il a été
question durant cette visite officielle
au Canada d'approvisionnement en nickel
on cobalt en lithium par les Canadiens
pour les besoins de Volkswagen lire cela
funderleion a également évoqué des
partenariats commerciaux avec des pays
producteurs de ces minerais comme
l'Australie comme le Chili comme le
Mexique donc la palette de notre diplôme
de nos actions de nos de les cordes que
nous avons à notre arc inclut également
ce que pour appeler une nouvelle
diplomatie minérale une diplomatie
minérale après la diplomatie pétrolière
la diplomatie minérale il y a une
nouvelle géopolitique du verre de la
transition énergétique du Green Deal qui
est en train de se mettre en place mais
ces pays d'abidjanko est-ce qu'ils ont
voulu nous vendre leur matière première
je veux dire vous à vous le voulez avoir
à vous produire avec un coût écologique
certains le minerai à un neuron kilo et
le vendre à des pays européens on
voulait pas du tout ça les états
producteurs veulent soit taxer fortement
le produit soit remonter la chaîne de
valeur c'est-à-dire en fait non pas
vendre le minerai ou le métal mais
vendre les batteries de voiture
électrique et pourquoi pas les voitures
électriques même demain
et ils ne veulent pas être des états
miniers et ils veulent l'être des
électro-états il y a eu des
électro-état donc il faut regarder notre
sous-sol chez nous aussi pas seulement
voir les fournisseurs mais voir comment
mais on dit qu'on produira jamais 100%
nous on sera jamais moto suffisant
jamais non plus la souveraineté pure
chimiquement pure n'existe pas mais une
forme de souveraineté existe la
souveraineté elle passe en particulier
par des alliances avec des avec des pays
producteurs donc avec qui allons nous
créer des liens d'interdépendance elle
passe par le recyclage on va pouvoir
davantage recycler parce qu'on va avoir
de plus en plus de batterie de voiture
recyclées tandis ou dans 15 ans et comme
ça ce sera une source de matière
première et puis après reste la partie
production sur notre sol on produira pas
tout par exemple je peux vous dire qu'on
produira pas assez de terre rare par
rapport à nos besoins pas cette coballe
par rapport à nos besoins on pourra pas
tout produire mais on peut produire une
partie on pourra produire une grande
partie du lithium dont nous avons besoin
et retrouver un peu de souveraineté et
puis la question ultime c'est ce qu'on
va réussir le pari de sécuriser
justement ces approvisionnements en
métaux stratégique pour réussir notre
transition énergétique on sait jouable
c'est une course qui est gagnée ou plus
certains diront perdus d'avance alors
d'abord on part très en retard parce que
les Chinois ont pris 20 ans avant nous
que ces matières premières allaient
devenir le nouveau pétrole dancehaoping
l'aurait dit en 1992 et cela fundalayan
l'a dit en 2022 donc il s'est passé 30
ans depuis en revanche on peut rattraper
notre retard et on remarque que les
Européens mais surtout les Américains
pour des raisons de sécurité nationale
parce que ces ressources certes dans
leur industrie de défense ils ont pas du
tout envie de dépendre des Chinois pour
faire voler leur F-35 l'équivalent de
notre rafale et bien accélère donc il y
a un rattrapage qui est en train de se
faire serons-nous souverains à 100% non
il y aura des interdépendants demain
avec d'autres pays il va falloir choisir
ses nouveaux alliés ce sera peut-être
plus l'Arabie Saoudite ce sera
l'Indonésie ce sera l'Australie ce sera
le Chili ce sera la Bolivie ce sera le
Mexique et peut-être d'autres pays la
souveraineté relative pour autant sera
une souveraineté qui sera la résultante
de l'agrégation de toutes ces solutions
là encore une fois on part avec du
retard voilà merci Guillaume pitro merci
je rappelle votre livre La guerre des
métaux rares aux éditions les liens qui
libèrent merci à vous
alors on a vu le lithium occupe une
place centrale dans la transition
énergétique on l'a dit on le trouve
notamment dans les batteries les
voitures électriques mais comment ne
plus être dépendant de la Chine on l'a
dit des pays d'Amérique latine et s'il
était possible parce que ça l'est de
relocaliser cette activité en France
manuel de la gare le lithium aussi
appelé or blanc et l'une des ressources
les plus recherchées dans la course à la
transition énergétique on le trouve dans
les batteries et notamment celle qui
équipe nos véhicules électriques avec
pour objectif la fin des voitures
thermiques en 2035 la demande en lithium
explose mais alors comment faire face où
trouvons-nous le lithium et comment
l'extraire
nous avons rendez-vous en banlieue
parisienne chez l'un des leaders du
marché français et Ramette leur
technique extraire en Argentine le
lithium contenu dans la saumure un
liquide se trouve en plusieurs
kilomètres sous terre face au mur c'est
ça c'est de l'eau très très salée 10
fois plus salé que l'eau de mer et à
l'intérieur ben vous le voyez pas mais
il y a du lithium et donc le but du
travail des ramettes ça a été de trouver
un procédé pour extraire les capter le
lithium qui à l'intérieur de cette de
cette eau très salée et le transformer
en carbonate de lithium et le carbone
abitium c'est utilisé pour fabriquer des
batteries Lithium de vos voitures
électriques début 2022 et ramène
installe Sephora dans la province de
Salta en Argentine un projet à 345
millions d'euros le plus difficile n'est
pas de puiser la saumure mais d'élaborer
un procédé pour en extraire le lithium
on va la faire passer à travers des
colonnes et ces colonnes on va la
remplir avec une épaule à lithium donc
on a déposé des brevets là dessus et
c'était éponge Alicia en fait elle va
capter le lithium qui a dans la saumure
ce lithium ensuite on va continuer à le
purifier le nettoyer on va le concentrer
et c'est cette poudre blanche qui va
être utilisée par les fabricants de
batterie lithium ici en Argentine
d'autres forages sont en cours de
construction l'objectif est de produire
à terme 24000 tonnes de lithium par an
soit l'équivalent de 500 000 batteries
de voiture mais ce n'est pas suffisant à
l'horizon 2040 c'est à dire dans 20 ans
c'est pas loin il nous faudra 40 fois
plus de lithium chaque année que ce
qu'on consomme aujourd'hui c'est énorme
je suis pas sûr qu'il y ait des on est
déjà connu dans l'histoire de l'humanité
une augmentation de besoin aussi rapide
et donc forcément ça veut dire que
derrière il faut qu'on mette en place
des nouvelles mines des nouvelles
exploitations des nouvelles usines aussi
de raffinage pour être capable de
produire ces
méthodes ces batteries qui viendront
alimenter nos véhicules électriques et
nous permettront de décarboner les
transports qui vous le rappelle
représentent bonhomme allant entre un
quart et un tiers de nos émissions de
CO2 annuelle on a fait des travaux un
peu plus prédictifs si vous voulez pour
essayer d'évaluer la probabilité qu'on
trouve du lithium en fonction de tout ce
qu'on sait de la géologie et ces travaux
nous ont montré qu'on est sans doute le
pays européen ou un des pays européens
on a le plus de chance de trouver de
lithium
ce qui a aujourd'hui nous consommions
peu de lithium principalement des piles
ou de petites batteries d'appareils
ménagers la totalité de nos besoins en
or blanc provient de l'étranger mais les
géants du secteur anticipent l'avenir en
multipliant leurs sources
d'approvisionnement et en les
rapprochant de la France
nous avons des équipes d'exploration de
géologues qui parcourent le monde à la
recherche des nouveaux gisements qui
permettront de continuer à produire du
lithium on parcourt le monde et parmi
les nombreux projets que nous avons nous
pouvons parler du projet en Alsace ou
nous projetons également de produire du
lithium à partir de source géothermales
mais ça reste un projet pour l'instant
qui est à l'étude mais réaliser un tel
projet en France n'est pas si simple
réglementation étude d'impact
acceptation sociale si Eramet réussi son
pari l'usine n’ouvrira pas ses portes
avant de nombreuses années et risquerait
même d'arriver derrière son plus gros
concurrent à Beauvoir dans l'Allier
Imerys vient d'annoncer l'ouverture
d'une mine géante de lithium en réalité
c'est en exploitant un gisement de
kaolin que les ingénieurs se sont
aperçus que les seuls étaient également
riches en lithium près d'un million de
tonnes d'or blanc serait enfouis dans
ses sols mais contrairement à la mine
ici ce petit métal n'est pas emprisonné
dans un liquide mais dans la roche la
première étape c'est que vous avez une
roche qui est solide il va falloir déjà
la transformer en poudre donc vous
imaginez qu'il va falloir effectivement
la concasser la broyer finement et tout
ça ça va consommer beaucoup d'énergie
dans cette roche qu'on a broyé donc on
va vouloir le récupérer donc on va
commencer par le dissoudre en général
dans de l'acide donc c'est pas dangereux
en tant que tel par contre il faut pas
avoir de rejet dans l'environnement et
c'est un point important parce que
évidemment ça n'a de sens d'ouvrir des
mines que si ces mines sont ce qu'on
appelle responsables
alors que cette mine ne pourra être
opérationnelle avant 5 ans les prix du
lithium explosent aujourd'hui la tonne
se négocie 50000 euros contre 6400 en
[Musique]
on vient de le voir on peut extraire des
métaux stratégiques dans des mines ou
alors miser sur le recyclage notamment
des batteries des voitures électriques
bonjour Benoît bonjour vous êtes
co-fondateur et président du directoire
de Vercors aujourd'hui qu'on dise les
choses les batteries des voitures
électriques sont fabriqués pas en France
elles le seront d'ici trois ans grâce à
vous mais aujourd'hui tout ça vient
d'Asie la Corée du Sud la Chine ça vient
en partie d'Asie mais ça vient déjà un
petit peu d'Europe il y a plusieurs
usines qui ont été construites par des
acteurs asiatiques coréens en
l'occurrence il y a LG en Pologne qui
par exemple fournit les batteries de la
Zoé il y a également SKS Samsung qui se
développe en Hongrie mais pour l'Europe
de l'Ouest effectivement on va être dans
les premiers à produire et à fournir des
batteries dans vos batteries donc
destinées aux voitures électriques on
retrouvera et c'est le thème de cette
émission des métaux stratégiques lithium
nickel ou m'arrêter un cuivre cobalt
graphite terre rare moi j'ai qu'une
seule question en 2025 mon saut vous
sourcer vos approvisionnements vous
allez prendre du lithium par exemple ou
du cobalt ou Chine République
démocratique du Congo quels sont ces
pays alors on a que vous choisissez vous
ne choisirez pas alors il y a des choses
qu'on choisit de choses qu'on choisit
pas un tout petites choses et dans les
batteries n'a pas de terrain et puis on
a du cobalt du lithium du manganèse on a
du cuivre et de l'aluminium sur les ce
qu'on appelle les foiles donc les
feuillards ça c'est les métaux qui sont
recyclés d'ailleurs sur les lits en
passant de d'usage primaire qui ont été
différents sur le cobalt le lithium et
le manganèse nous travaillons avec
Renault et puis également avec d'autres
partenaires pour localiser en Europe la
production et je peux citer l'accord qui
était passé avec le groupe Managem qui
travaille alors en Afrique du Nord mais
également avec le groupe terrafamé en
Finlande pour produire du manganèse pour
que nous puissions l'incorporer dans les
batteries donc nous avons le souci de
avoir une chaîne de valeur locale avec
des partenaires ce sera pas tout local
le 8e va venir peut-être un petit peu
d'Europe mais aussi l'Amérique du Sud
mais aussi d'Asie mais aussi mais aussi
pourquoi parce qu'en fait nous sommes en
train de produire ces usines
mais la chaîne à mon toute la chaîne de
valeur nécessaire à la production de
symétrique mais pas encore structuré en
Europe et en train de se structurer bon
et on voit bien qu'il y a des
aujourd'hui il y a des productions qui
se relocalisent notamment le lithium on
l'a vu dans l'actualité avec
erame ou Imerys là encore il y a des
partenariats qui sont en cours pour vous
fournir vous fournir en lithium
absolument et c'est très important nous
notre enjeu c'est d'être fourni en
lithium d'une manière responsable je
pense que du lithium responsable
traçable c'est très important et
également pérenne c'est très à cheval
là-dessus oui c'est important parce que
le consommateur le demande est-ce que
vous avez refusé aujourd'hui comme ça
approvisionnements ce qu'on a refusé
aujourd'hui c'est des sources
d'approvisionnement qui sont pas
transparentes sur leur origine je donne
un exemple il y a sur le marché des
acteurs qui sont capables de nous
fournir avec une approche relativement
directe et d'autres qu'on appelle les
traders qui vont en fait mélanger des
matières sans trop nous donner
l'information du sourcing ça aujourd'hui
on refuse on dit non s'il n'est pas
capable de tracer la source c'est
quelque chose qui ne nous convient pas
bon dans un second temps j'ai prévu de
récolter
de ces métaux stratégiques sur
d'anciennes batteries qui arriveront en
fin de vie c'est pas pour tout de suite
parce que
les batteries qui sont en fin de vie
aujourd'hui elles arrivent quoi elles
arrivent au compte-goutte donc c'est le
sujet c'est pas le sujet d'aujourd'hui
c'est le sujet de dans 5 ans ou 3
minimum là plus que ça parce que en fait
ce que ce que nous testeurs à savoir
c'est qu'une batterie c'est quelque
chose qui dure longtemps et une voiture
électrique aujourd'hui nous les durées
de vie sur lesquelles nous partons en
termes de conception de batterie c'est
beaucoup plus qu'une voiture
traditionnelle à essence c'est une
voiture qui va être capable de faire 500
000 700 000 km donc ça nous renvoie dans
15 ans dans 20 ans et effectivement à ce
moment là on va avoir cette économie
circulaire pour l'instant il nous faut
incorporer des nouveaux matériaux donc
pas avant 15 ou 20 ans qu'on aura
vraiment du des giga Factory avec du
recyclage avec des métaux stratégiques
issus du recyclage d'anciennes batteries
arrivant en fin de vie on va la voir dès
le démarrage avec quelques batteries
mais les volumes vont avoir besoin de
croître on va avoir également le
recyclage des batteries ce qu'on appelle
les SCRA qui seront pas à la bonne
qualité dans le cadre de la du démarrage
des usines en Europe mais ça fera une
fraction puis elle va grandir grandir
grandir et en 2040 on aura une fraction
très importante qui sera issue de
recyclage où est-ce qu'on en est sinon
de la technologie de recyclage des
batteries il paraît que le progrès sont
absolument incroyables et qu'on sait
quasiment récupérés 90% notamment du
lithium qui sont contenus dans les
batteries le grand public le sait peu en
fait des séparations par traitement ce
qu'on appelle
électrochimique vont permettre vraiment
cette séparation et cette réutilisation
parce qu'on retrouve la même qualité des
métaux en fait je le dis d'une manière
assez simple la meilleure mine
aujourd'hui pour des matériaux pour
batterie c'est une batterie c'est une
beaucoup plus concentré dans une
batterie que ce qu'on va trouver dans la
nature sauf que tout ça ce sera dans 20
ans on a dit le recyclage ça sera dans
15 20 ans première Zoé du groupe Renault
vont arriver en fin de vie pas tout de
suite mais en 2020 2030 2035 et puis ça
va augmenter progressivement ce
recyclage des métaux il est quand même
pas simple évidemment il puisqu'il est
propre alors il est pas très coûteux
parce qu'en fait c'est moins cher sur le
plan énergétique d'extraire du nickel
d'une batterie que de l'écrire dans la
nature la concentration est beaucoup
plus élevée est-ce qu'il est propre oui
s'il est fait correctement ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va dissoudre ces
métaux dans un bain spécial et qu'en
fait on va ensuite les extraire c'est
une technique extrêmement classique de
la métallurgie avec des métaux et là
pour le coup je la prends qui peuvent
être réutilisés plusieurs fois et
jusqu'où on va jusqu'où va cette
économie circulaire il y a pas de limite
quelque part c'est comme le verre vous
savez que le verre aujourd'hui est
recyclé en fait une infinité de fois et
ben c'est pareil avec les métaux des
batteries parce que c'est important de
bien le comprendre une batterie ne
consomme pas les métaux au bout de 15
ans 20 ans chagramme de lithium
chagramme de cobalt est toujours là et
ça ça a une vraie valeur économique
environnementale et c'est cette valeur
là que nous allons collectivement venir
chercher en recyclant ces batteries
allez merci Benoît le meilleur Merci à
VOUS cofondateur et président du
directoire de Vercors merci merci
beaucoup et si pour retrouver notre
souveraineté la solution venait de nos
plantes capables de donner une seconde
vie à nos métaux
[Musique]
alors on vient de le voir on aura du mal
à satisfaire notre demande en
métostratégique heureusement certaines
plantes peuvent nous aider bonjour
Émilie et c'est le combat d'une
chercheuse c'est Claude Grison elle a du
CNRS elle a reçu le Prix de l'inventeur
européen décerné par l'Office européen
des brevets et ce prix vient couronné
cette intuition qu'elle a eu il y a 15
ans et que peu avait à l'époque à savoir
que le ressources minérales mondiales
était en voie d'épuisement et que et
bien certaines plantes pouvaient devenir
des outils de la chimie du futur une
chimie propre qui se passe de seulement
chimique donc ces plantes quoi auraient
un super pouvoir alors est-ce capable en
fait de survivre sur des sites
industriels très dégradés mais aussi de
les dépolluer alors c'est le cas par
exemple du tabouret bleu ou de la menthe
aquatique mais aussi de la renouer du
Japon ou de la jussie d'eau ce sont deux
plantes exotiques qui prolifèrent
aujourd'hui dans nos rivières et nos
cours d'eau et ces plantes devraient pas
en théorie être chez nous aujourd'hui
mais que le réchauffement climatique et
bien elles ont trouvé un terrain de jeu
privilégié il faut savoir que c'est un
véritable fléau David elle faisait toute
vie aquatique elle détruisent les
écosystèmes fragilise les berges qui du
coup la menace de s'effondrer mais
malgré ça ces plantes peuvent être de
précieux alliés en fait la société de
Claude Grison bio inspire et sur le
terrain 6 mois de l'année justement pour
leur faucher la tête pour leur couper la
tête qui est c'est les plantes dont du
coup plus de nutriments pour proliférer
et puis du coup et bien elles vont
pouvoir ensuite capter pour nous des
éléments métalliques voilà c'est là que
l'on reboucle avec le thème de
l'émission aujourd'hui les métaux
stratégiques ici sont des métaux qui
arrivent en fin de vie on les appelle
les effluents industriels une fois
utilisés les industriels vont les
mélanger à de la chose qui va générer
une boue extrêmement toxique et
métallique et censée partir dans des
sites confinés le problème c'est que ça
coûte cher et puis surtout ces sites ils
arrivent aujourd'hui à saturation ce qui
peut donner des abus on a tous en
mémoire ces fameuses scandales de bouts
toxiques qui avaient à l'époque qui a
été déversé dans la Méditerranée et
c'est là qu'intervient bio inspire
justement plutôt que de laisser partir
dans le sol ces métaux qui sont toxiques
mais néanmoins stratégiques pourquoi ne
pas les récupérer c'est pour ça qu'elle
a noué des partenariats avec des
industriels dont elle préfère taire le
nom pour des raisons de confidentialité
des industriels qui aujourd'hui ne
veulent plus participer à cette
pollution à grande échelle qui joue donc
le jeu de ce recyclage végétal justement
ce recyclage écologique à quoi il
ressemble alors je vous propose de
revenir à nos plantes exotiques vous
savez celle à qui on a coupé la tête une
fois récolté elles vont être séchées
broyées puis réduit en poudre une poudre
qui va ensuite jouer le rôle d'éponge
végétale elle va en fait venir absorber
ses déchets métalliques des déchets qui
au contact de la poudre vont se
transformer en écho catalyseur c'est un
petit peu complexe mais grosso modo
c'est métaux en fait ils vont retrouver
leurs qualités originelle et seront donc
prêts pour une seconde vie dans la
chimie donc c'est un recyclage 100%
naturel est-ce que ça marche pour
l'ensemble pour tous nos métaux
stratégiques alors pour l'instant la
start-up récupère deux familles de
métaux stratégiques les terres dont vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure mais également
les platinoïdes typiquement le le
palladium qui aujourd'hui est super
critique c'est bien simple dans la
chimie on le sait plus s'en passer que
ce soit dans l'industrie pharmaceutique
ou automobile et ce depuis le diesel
gate puisque le Palladium est qui
aujourd'hui est tous nos pots
catalytiques de nos voitures les besoins
ils sont elles aujourd'hui que le cours
du Palladium est littéralement flamber
il coûte plus cher que l'or aujourd'hui
et comme c'est la Russie qui nous
fournit je vous fais pas un dessin nos
approvisionnements sont directement
menacés aujourd'hui donc ce recyclage
végétal il arrive à poinommer exactement
et en plus c'est la belle leçon que nous
donne les plantes et que ces éco
catalyseurs ils sont en fait plus
performants que les que les catalyseurs
conventionnel toujours cette Eco
palladium je vous parle de lui il est
très stable et du coup on a plus besoin
d'utiliser des quantités importantes de
palladium on évite donc ce phénomène que
connaissent tous les chimistes le
phénomène de déperdition Emilie
escado-rométo qui pourrait eux aussi
atteindre concernés par ce recyclage
végétal alors bien inspire travail
actuellement sur le cuivre le zinc le
manganèse et le nickel pour le COBAL
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué mais à
la société est sur le coup donc vous
voyez on n'a pas fini entendre parler du
pouvoir des plantes et d'ailleurs Claude
Grison est formelle chaque plante à sa
spécialité et tous les métaux lourds
peuvent au final être captés allez merci
Émilie merci David voilà c'est la fin de
pourvu que ça dure l'émission qui rend
les correspondances sur Public Sénat
émission voir re-revoir sur Public Sénat
le replay c'est toujours public sénat.fr
rendez-vous dans deux semaines
[Musique]
c'était pourvu que ça dure avec le
soutien déco des déesses
[Musique]